kerry is with us to start off this hour
in detroit michigan hi carrie how are
you
hi dave how are you guys doing today
better than we deserve what's up
so i left my corporate job at the end of
february
and i finished up a certification
that i've been working on for about a
year and a half in
animal training at the end of march
i've been working since the end of
february on
building website ordering business cards
networking but i'm at a point now where
i'm i guess i'm nervous to
pull a trigger and publish my website
and distribute my business cards at
local businesses
and i guess i'm i'm nervous
i guess i'm looking for some advice on
just how to not
feel like a fraud since i'm still
new at this and how do i even go about
setting my prices
when i'm still learning and
i'm still you know a novice um
not a quote-unquote expert yet
yeah carrie i'm going to tell you the
number one way
to get rid of this feeling of the fear
the insecurity the doubt the imposter
syndrome all that the number one thing
is to start doing stuff no no no listen
i know that sounds simple but here
there's actually
there's a practical implication of this
okay i tell people all the time
the antidote to fear is action nothing
will
silence your fear of doing the thing
like doing the thing so go do the thing
nothing will silence your fear of
publishing the website like pressing
publish or taking your business cards to
the local
you know vets or wherever you're you
know there
the action steps that you take
and every time that you take a step of
faith that you take a step of action you
actually start to do stuff with this
business
your fear lessons that voice in your
head gets quieter
your confidence grows and you go oh my
gosh i did it and i survived what else
can i do
but if you're waiting around until this
feeling of ready comes over you
it will never happen so like obedience
training for dogs
um actually i'm going to be working with
exotic birds
who who's your market what what what are
you
what problems are you birds but you
teach exotic birds behave
i am i am teaching exotic birds how to
behave and surprisingly there is a
market for
it and surprisingly you can do that
that's amazing that's the surprising
part
so um yes so i'll be training
like parrots mainly um
parrots are one of the most re-homed
animals
um because they won't behave because
they won't behave
they're not meant to be in homes they're
meant to be in the wild
they're not domesticated so they get
mean
they're mean they're destructive and you
train them to not be so mean
instead of putting them on the grill
people re-home them okay
yes have you checked out the market in
detroit so long
like is there like do you know the
market like where the parrot owners
hang out in detroit i do so when i left
my corporate job
i took a job in a exotic bird
store basically just doing retail sales
which is horrible but it's giving me
the opportunity to network with bird
owners
i've also been networking with local
bird rescues
um to so
are you afraid that you cannot train
them
i've i've i have had some experience
but i i haven't experienced every issue
yet
you know and i i haven't i've been doing
this 30 years and
this is the first parrot called we've
never so i've never experienced this
issue before but i'm winging my way
through it no pun intended
but uh all right all right here's the
thing
here's the thing so the only thing i can
draw parallel on is i was with a guy
who's been
as a professional dog trainer for
hunting dogs
uh back last fall we had this long talk
about hunting dogs
just because i was interested in what he
was doing and the and what he was
selling them for unbelievable money
because he's apparently very very big
and he had this one dog he got
and uh he could not train it
he said i've been doing this 20 years
and he said this dog was an absolute
butthole
you could not train this dog and he said
so i just sent it back to the owner
and i didn't charge him because i
couldn't help him
right so what's wrong with that strategy
no that's a good strategy you can that's
that is that is going to be a part of
the journey
i don't think you need to dread that and
fear that i think you need to accept
that
there's going to be there's going to be
a bird you can
there's going to be periods you don't
know what to do it okay i lived on i
lived on a farm i had a horse back uh
years ago and i same situation sent this
horse to be trained and they brought it
back to me they said we can't we we've
broken a bazillion horses we can't break
this horse i ended up selling the horse
i couldn't
he couldn't be trained so that's gonna
happen you just accept that rather than
fear it just accept it but know that
the majority of the time you're gonna
have
parrots that you can train based on your
education
and certification and you're gonna be
able to help these people but here's
what i want to do i got a challenge for
you
i want you to get one customer i don't
care who i don't care where and i don't
care what you charge
you get one customer tell them you're my
first customer i'm gonna do it for three
dollars
but go do it for god's sake do it and
when you do it's gonna do so much for
your confidence yeah yeah just get out
there and start swinging you know get at
the plate swing the bat
don't wait until you're not scared to do
the thing you want to do do it scared
the antidote to fear
is action the first time i sat down in
this chair and
got in front of the microphone i
couldn't hardly talk i was so nervous
and now my pulse rate doesn't even
change you know but there are people
that walk up in front of an audience and
break out and sweat do it scared
play scared the first time you got on
stage i was there you were scared i used
this example all the time because i
think sometimes we look at people doing
things that seem scary we think oh well
they're fearless they're just confident
they just have this certain gene that i
don't have
they're doing it despite their fear and
so kerry
if you're waiting for permission for
someone to give you enough approval or
someone to
tell you you're it's not going to happen
i need you to go get a customer any
customer
anywhere for any amount of money any
parent
and help this person with their parent
this week and watch how that first
customer
that first interaction do it scared
we'll build your confidence we work with
dysfunctional parrots oh my gosh this is
so awesome but i love that she said what
if i get a pair of
shoes jokes we've never we've never got
a call on parrots before this is this is
going to be part of the journey
she could use she's just gotta you gotta
embrace the humor in this i'm gonna wing
it yeah i can't help you this one's a
bird brain i mean you know this is just
so
you gotta wing it this one's a bird
brain i couldn't help it you shouldn't
you could stay on the line i wanna send
you my book kelly you're sending my book
business boutique that
chapter two carrie read chapter two on
fear you got this for any of you out
there that are unemployed
shut up i mean she's a parrot trainer my
god
this is the ramsey show